so as a nation we are experiencing a
significant increase in drug overdose
deaths
the dea and pact coalition partner up
twice a year to give communities a
chance to help stop this
here's more information on this month's
pill take back day
so pill take back day april 24th what
does that mean what is this concept
of pill take back so what we're doing
is we partner with the dea and a bunch
of other agencies
in town twice a year to do a big round
up of all the unused
medication what we know is people
will leave unused medication in their
medicine cabinet and sometimes
kids and other people can go in and take
that and
we want to uh discourage
diversion of all of these medications
into
unsafe uses tell us about the event and
how people
can get involved it's going to be
saturday april 24th
from 10 a.m to 2 p.m and we have
multiple locations this year we have
we have about six locations and we tried
to
put them in in different areas where it
made it more
accessible for people in the community
to be able to to make it to one of the
locations
we have we have a location over at the
henderson police station
at 300 south green valley parkway we
have one
at the north las vegas northwest area
command over at 3755
west washburn we have one at the las
vegas metropolitan police department
northwest area command and we also have
one
at the northeast area command we also
have two locations um
smith's uh and walmart are partners with
us
as well with pac coalition wow so
no excuses you guys are covering the
valley that's great
um so what should people not bring to
the event
what what is not accepted
um so the what we don't we don't like to
take
are needles um and we also we have
alternatives for
for properly disposing of any type of
needles
but not not for take back event um and
aerosols and liquids
we would like to avoid taking as well
just because
um for the disposal process it it's not
good so
we only take the prescription drugs that
if you bring them in bottles that's fine
um just make sure you mark out your name
and
any type of patient information we may
not be able to take it but we can
definitely tell you where to dispose of
it if we need to
what we are seeing is we are seeing an
increase in overdose deaths
um in 2020 we saw a significant spike
and if we can divert all of these unused
medications if we can
um stop the first time someone uses
a drug that they got from someone else's
medicine cabinet
we can definitely prevent this problem
before it becomes
an issue and isn't that what we're all
here to do is make our community safer
and this is the easiest way you can do
so
just dispose of your unused medication
there's two different websites that you
can go to
one is drug-free las vegas.org and then
the other
is takebackday.dea.gov and
on there it's more of a national
location search finder so if you're
if you're wanting to tell your family
members in different states they can
look at that as well
that is great make sure you spread the
word the next pill take back day is
april 24th from 10 a.m to 2 p.m
and there will be drop-off locations
across the valley you can head to
drugfreelasvegas.org for more
information